Welcome back to Drew's News.
Well, now it's time for our pick
from Drew's Little Yellow Book.
(audience cheering)
And today I've got a secret weapon.
(Drew laughing)
What is this?
It's a spaghetti measurer.
(everyone laughing)
That's right.
This is one person, just gonna say, that is not how I do it.
I'm like, to me, this is one person.
Right?
That's a serving.
Oh, so the little hole, that's a single serving.
I'm trying-
this, okay, so, oh right.
This would be a two person.
And then that's a one, two, and three and four,
or as I like to say, one, two, three and four.
Anyway, it measures, you know,
a healthy amount of pasta,
perfectly portioned out
for the amount of people that's eating.
If that's goals, good.
I'm going one hole up, all right.
Also, don't forget to check out
our on the go show with our podcast, every weekday.
You'll get a full episode of our podcast in your ears,
and you can just stream it wherever you get podcasts.
I have to say, I really love the news for podcasts too,
so you can get some interesting stories and, you know,
takes on people who are snoring.
(cheerful music)